voilà chaque oeil maintenant rihanna
carembault et jardiner
bonsoir à rihanna méline tu as des
bottes à asi asi aucune différence mais
je le mets un peu loin vous êtes ici
tous les deux ce soir pour un film
excellent ce qui est une habitude chez
vous mon cher mon cher jugnot un gentil
non mais c'est vrai la série pas mal oui
ça marche pas mal
je viens là wen ont cédé des choix là le
film de jean yves est un film différent
c'est bien plus en plus âpre mais l'ours
un film s'appelle trois petites filles
de jean loup hubert effectivement mais
d'abord pour rendre hommage à un gérard
jugnot pour les choristes
toutefois le fait ça ouais bah chaque
fois oui
non non le fameux christophe pour
astérix c'est parfait donc ouais
maintenant je me méfie des hommages
là ça y est c'est fait et fait bien
c'est vrai qu'avant les avants les
corriger tinevez d'être maintenant vous
êtes une star c'est bien triste
j'étais tout leader je suis un plan de
t-bonds 8 millions d'entrées quand même
un oui c'est pas ma faim ces domaines et
non seulement c'est un succès hexagonal
mais ça va être un succès mondial parce
que les canadiens pouvaient sa
formidable miramax adore le film est
sélectionné par la france pour les
oscars c'est génial normalement ça
marche à singapour partout non c'est fou
c'est faux c'est fou syrien de nuire ces
fruits sujet
oui il faut dire aussi qu'en monsieur
batignole passées à tes l'évidence ça
fait douze ennemis millions de
téléspectateurs je suis vachement
content que c'est la meilleure audience
d'un film à la télévision sur tf1 depuis
1998 quand même te dire d'aller justesse
et regus voilà ravis du bien la télé
maintenant tu es tout temps avec adriana
karembeu va très bien ils étaient
ensemble toute la journée
géotop les grandes idées non ce qui me
fait très plaisir c'est que c'était pas
des films attendus
en tout cas les choristes personne ne
croyait à succès entre que parce ce
magot et donc ça fait rêver tout le
monde parce que du coup bas il ya des
tas de films qui devait pas se faire qui
se font même ce film là où moi j'ai pas
un grand rôle mécanique un très beau
film il ya il ya une lumière plus grande
qui se pose de financer ces agréables
succès aussi ouais
en tous les cas vos films marchent
quoi qu'on en dise voilà pas le cas
c'est pas le cas de tout le monde
oui prenons au hasard tu l'as mérité un
petit t-shirt arrêt pour frimer dans le
métier voilà
monsieur
mais bon restons dans le prêt-à-porter
adriana je pense est apte à prendre une
petite jupe
voilà c'est un petit cadeau à ses
vignobles
présenté il passe là-bas se mange froid
pas bien le ton jeudi c'est jolie pitt
n'ont jamais vulgaire c'est la
collection jamais vulgaire vous êtes une
énorme sa furie dans les bronzés 3 vous
avez exigé des celui qui héberge le plus
c'est vrai et remixeur les imiter oui
oui les autres sont au chaud non ils
veulent tout couché avec vous qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un effet ça fait que toutes
les femmes soient sur vous comme ça je
le disais moi donc j'ai telle affiche
tous les deux de trois petites filles de
jean louis baird ils nous ont bien
traités sur le film très bien ouais je
viens carlos avait une disposition quand
même français d'accord faut partager
partager les touche pas c'était très
bien de moi je voyais pas faire pipi n'y
avait pas de toilettes ans et une autre
allure très rock'n'roll l'a fait pendant
deux mois l année dans la règle dans la
garrigue
enfin dans le maquis mais il y avait des
trappes elle l avait des châtaignes
je fais attention ça peut faire vaincre
au il y avait des petits cochons
c'est une fille toute simple
ouais ça c'est hélas hélas il a eu cette
idée de ma roue d'engager 200 avec dans
son filmage sort parce qu'il m'a vu un
sur votre plateau de télé qui jean loup
mais non c'est vrai j'ai vu du nombre de
gonzesse qui sont choisis et nous rien
on se tape sur la personne n'appelle
jamais personne ne veut nous c'est
lamentable mais le rythme de la
promotion ce moment c'est pas trop dur
inhabité ça c'est vrai c'est lourd c'est
du rhin personne n'a envie c'est
terrible parce qu'il faut sourire est de
bonne humeur dire que le film est bien
que l'équipe était géniale est tous là
c'était une grande famille mais on parle
d'un crime qui est très très très très
beau bien facile quand les films sont
bien accueillis quelques unes sont de
qualité de genre ou il a fait un vrai
bon film qui parle de choses vraiment
peuvent toucher non il ya des gens qui
sortent tout à fait le bouleverser par
le film vous avez une fille ou non non
mais j'adorais le film s'il a deux fils
avait hélas oublié déjà ah oui c'est
vrai
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est adrien
garrigues il est pas trop entreprenant
avec vous un jugnot n'ont pas ces sons
doux pendant un tournage vraiment grâce
à lui j'ai été vraiment à l'aise
il m'a fait beaucoup rire donné beaucoup
de conseils j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour toi
et merci encore
pas céder en bradant cumuler la langue
oui j'en ai plus parce que je savais pas
ben ali comme on faire dessiner la ville
comme dans la vie très bien pu tuer
jolie forme était pas la langue au
cinéma voilà tu es assez honnête ascione
j'aurais pu tu m'avais fait de cette
fois qu'il est là mais non on n'a pas
forcément mais bon là mais c'est vrai
que c'était assez bizarre quand même
pour moi embrasser quelqu'un qu'on
connaît pas c'est ça nous arrive pas
tous les jours j'avais un peu non je
n'avais je sais pas c'est étrange non
c'est un métier ça c'est sûr que c'était
moi quand jean lou m'a dit voilà je vais
te marier à adriana karembeu est tombé
par terre son ca et c'est très amusant
ce métier bon il n'ya pas que ça c'est
aussi si terrible il y aura beau jour tu
vas tuer jean rochefort dans ce film va
violer jacqueline maillan bon c'est
quand on joue avec adriana on doit être
obligé de rentrer le ventre toute la
journée non
bon bah maintenant maintenant on va
passer à la promotion du film adriana
d'accord donc c'est un film qui
s'appelle trois petites filles de jean
loup hubert sortie le 29 septembre avec
vous deux
morgane cabot sabrina ouazani et lucie
de saint thibault alors je suis le pichu
vous le fait dire oui on va voir donc
ces trois ados dont une est d'origine
algérienne est en pleine révolte parce
que sa famille veut retourner vivre en
algérie et la mariée de force avec son
cousin
alors pour éviter ça les trois ados
décide de contacter johnny depp et
vanessa paradis et de les convaincre
d'intervenir dans les médias voilà alors
la presse people annonce vanessa paradis
et johnny depp en corse donc les trois
gamines partent en corse
et là elle rencontre le couple que vous
formez tous les deux vous vous êtes gogo
danseuse et vous vaguement imprésario
oui genre de comme ça des animateurs qui
l'a rencontré cette femme et il a fait
travailler quoi c'est un petit petites
entreprises à 2 ouais on va voir à quoi
ressemblent les regarder votre caméra
vous dites magnéto serge tous les deux
en même temps
attention la ville rouge ouais magnéto
cherche